yeah welcome to this video playing p.m.
probably Sherlock samanta cell lock from
Greece okay let's play on the new zone
and test down this line from light from
upcoming book again check yep this is a
typical pawn sacrifice that wider
shouldn't accept funny enough is playing
all those moves absolutely instantly
okay so how to how to play this yeah
again I can first cavity five it's not
strictly necessary but it's a it's a
good news sonai g4 nitey form both them
both I interesting okay but first let's
play him some good positional loose and
see what he comes up with I personally
wouldn't allow a four button here he was
very young relaxed on that matter it
seems I wouldn't like to allow this kind
of hole who came should I go f6 not
quite sure
yeah I want to protect you five yeah
this is so the reason why i was a bit
bit reluctant to move it okay shouldn't
be a big deal can I threaten f4 now even
it's not so clear what this piece is
actually doing now on each form it
played an intended night f5 course but I
don't don't really see ya probably he
needed to do that just just retreated ok
let's use them the tempo here that I
have with f4 you can give give give me
the bishops I mean considers Bishop
power by capturing or worse retreated
and allowed Bishop f5 which really looks
looks terrible yeah he needed to take
know maybe maybe look oh no his son
playing ambitiously yeah why not I or
not ok so Bishop f5 there are some also
we should be four
I could also just play g6 yeah let's do
that
Bishop f5 he just has bishop i
frightened I don't know what check my
next move this
now I'm threatening to take on g3 using
the pin the c5 g1 diagonal let's have 94
in the mix
I don't think I'm bad I'm worse here I
have some some ideas on my own I mean it
looks am a bit too bit shaky but still
94 and takes yep so just drop back here
maybe he can think about taking on on c6
I'm not sure take and play ok maybe you
can actually take em and play a play
g-form i have created oh ok so this
wasn't wasn't really air on so c5b
should be seven as this song is this
good or should have five this whole EG
phone no I'm actually this is good I
need to make sure that g4 is not coming
yeah this was important i think i showed
the law g4 so easily if i go bishop at
five no next move it's really an awkward
pin he couldn't hear my plea bush away
at five immediately he has g4 to break
the pin and now I'm threatening it yeah
yeah this is ok maybe yeah exactly if
this is a movie I wanted to to suggest
maybe this is what you needed to do that
go see 5 he has a look d5 unfortunately
okay this means I probably need to do
that here and watch now I can play Queen
six just tech h3 so that you need to go
rogue to h1
maybe I can take take on d 2 ok and now
this Bishop b4 looks like an it's such
it's trouble yeah no it's no trouble its
winning check yeah kicking edge to e e
he gets look after to check and if he
goes back to g1 I take H 1 and then h3
is saying so I'm winning and I can use
the moves here idiotic the other with
the other one of course oh my home
hopefully this is to winning this would
be heartbreaking not to win this game ah
how idiotic is dead of course just the
rook check like I planned it
this is okay the check now really nuts
that's nothing okay let's grab this one
try to try to play in this way ah why
didn't I just play what I wanted to play
check yeah it's still quite good for
black but of course the other one was
just just an instant win time morning I
have the space advantage maybe with the
sea porn
now the time is more of a problem out
service king cut off so I'm basically
I'm enjoying this extra piece on c5 if
he takes the porn and games winning at
the end I have them I have the passport
him the seaborne check that's a winning
King important game white foreheads one
time yeah but I made it much more
difficult than then needed of course I
just you know I you heard me give the
line and then I just I just I just
expected him to play kings you want to
take and then because Luke f2 is so easy
let's just check f2 here and and Queen
Queen somewhere p.m. and this is over
mate this just made and then I forgot
forgot about that end and I just I just
took here yeah it's so very good yeah
but it made this a mate and so I needed
to need to to go through through all
this the end game with no time on the
clock it's still an interesting game
thanks for watching